hallo mein name ist meine lieben freunde
herzlich willkommen wir heute zur ersten
episode von die topnews de
es mit luca in dieser neuen serie werde
ich euch immer dienstags die lustigsten
tik tok zeigen die ich in den letzten
tagen so index habe auf der plattform
von da würd ich sagen fangen direkt an
mit dem ersten mehr gibt sich denn so
viel mühe bei einem tick tock wartet ist
mit ist von von laser die fresse du
laden mein therapeut meinte zunächst die
briefe schreiben an alle die mich
verletzt haben und die ganze breite ok
habe ich gemacht habe was mache ich mit
den kufen german ich habe eine andere
termins aber wieso machen wir weiter mit
dem nächsten tag noch video
als ich das nächste tik tok gesehen habe
habe ich mir wirklich gedacht wow
das stimmt
vielleicht kriegt jetzt auch so ein
break es ist halt die wahrheit wenn man
am 31 dezember geburtstag kann hat man
wirklich immer dieses jahr geburtstag
gewünscht
war klar dass nach so einem richtigen
brain härter wie mit dem geburtstag bei
mir so eine chance kommt unseren typ
einfach auf die fresse fliegt ja nach
einem typen der auf die fresse fliegt
kind das auf die fresse fliegt sehr gut
das wäre hundertprozentig ich mit meinen
freunden im krieg
[Musik]
hat sie müsli aus hass aus dem mund von
presse jalag.de happened to help genauso
habe ich auch kogler das video letztes
gesehen habe ich weiß ich sagte dass bei
solchen videos von mir auf meinem kanal
nahezu immer aber es ist wirklich 100
die wahrheit montags bis jetzt gerade
bei mir halt nicht mehr soweit sie noch
studiert haben oder mein abi gemacht
habe oder noch praktikum hatte keine
ahnung was es war immer so montags bis
freitags zu gefühl ins bett gegangen
direkt wieder aufgewacht und jetzt ja
bin ich dauerhaft nur ganz kurze info
bevor leute irgendwie wieder ausrasten
dem hund ist nichts passiert das hat der
selbst in die kommentare von seinem
eigenen tecdoc geschrieben aber trotzdem
krass stemmer foto wilson trägt machen
und ein hund läuft unter dem was also
ich wäre meines lebens nicht mehr
glücklich
[Musik]
alles klar alles klar
die hand
das ist mega krass und zwar ist es eine
brücke in japan und da sind so rinnen
allen dem asphalt drin also dass er aus
der auf dem asphalt drauf also etwas
manche leute für eine kreativität haben
wir dieser plattform ist wahnsinn kann
ich den sanften zungenkuss geben
ich wollte noch am samstag zugegeben
geht das nicht den kleinen und kein leck
[Musik]
danke also sehr nett aber nee danke
alles leute geworden flugzeuge im
fenster öffnet hektar kein scheidung und
meine 2 de camargo familien habe ich
noch kontakt von epic sony natürlich sc
empfängt der kämpfer in der nähe eines
vermieters ist halt auch wieder voll die
wahrheit zum beispiel bei dem ticker
wieder dass ich heute hochgeladen habe
das jetzt den ganzen morgen dran also
irgendwie 45 stunden oder so eine andere
machen den titel wieder und 12 sekunden
und machen auch millionen aufrufe wo ich
mir denke darum gebe ich mir so viel
weniger
das zum beispiel ich mein glas ist
lustig und glaube aber dass jetzt auf
dem ticket video hier auch irgendwie
500.000 oder eine million aufrufe oder
so um den dreh
das ist nicht mal sein video ja bisher
[Applaus]
[Musik]
humor so vertrackt dass nur ich sowas
müsste ich bin herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge luca hat einen
abgeparkten humor in germany we don't
say that kentucky is in germany ist
wieder so die wahrheit so die wahrheit
ist mir leider wieder sage
ich war oft nicht lustig aber dieser
dumme filter und damit dieser ton
verzerrung und feiert einfach und normal
aber machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten
sieg doch videos tatsächlich auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt in köln entstanden ist
und schauen wir uns jetzt als nächstes
kim kardashian kochen
durch den bürgern deinen kopf schon
wissen warum bin ich so was so witzig
wie wir es mir leute anzusprechen die
figur der bist und wirst du mich
gefunden wahrscheinlich da dieser
ordnungsamt typ gewesen wäre oder dieser
fahrkartenkontrolleur also ich habe ihm
direkt aufs maul gegeben
einfach sein vater im laptop gelandet
[Musik]
warum
macht man sowas ich weiß es tut mir leid
kommt dr
bei mir ist lieber zu hause ich habe
doch gesagt bei mir jetzt lieber zu
hause
ob für die sonne scheint also lustig
kenne was machst du ausländer heutigen
die fünfzehnte was ist das
93 was machst du heute des 15
egal als so ein flug ab ich habe mir ein
adventskalender vom ersten fc köln
gekauft haben direkt am 30 november
alles aufgegessen
es waren nicht mal dezember als man halt
schon leer war kommen allerdings jetzt
auch schon zum letzten tag das heutige
video und zwar könnt ihr gleich einfach
mal mit raten in den kommentaren ob
jeder die lösung findet bevor ich euch
das ding allerdings zeigen wollte ich
schon mal sagen liegt das video wenn es
euch gefallen hat diese neue serie tik
tok user und schreibt mal euren tik tok
nahm und in die kommentare und jetzt
kommt das letzte tick tock und danach
ist als video vorbei
[Gelächter]